well guys welcome back to another
episode of don't at me I'm here to tell
you that the rumors of my dong 'king
have been greatly exaggerated now I know
you guys really appreciate the reporting
that we've done along the lines of the
Tipu forces faze clan lawsuit over the
last several weeks and I want to tell
you we're working on more there's
another thread we're pulling on and I
hope to have something for you soon but
in the meantime there's a bit of a
sideshow to this whole drama that's
caught our interest and it has to do
with another huge Fortnite streamer
signed to face the question I present to
you is cloak see still actually on faze
clan
[Music]
now look I know that sounded a little
bit conspiratorial but stay with me here
now for this particular issue I brought
in a hired gun a little help someone
from the office in the back and no that
is not a green screen that is full of
you reporters researchers and editors
who make all the awesome content you've
come to rely on from these score eSports
and before I introduce him it is worth
saying that we reached out to cloaks for
this story and he has not yet had a
chance to respond if he is able to we
will of course update you now the man I
brought in to help us is a bit of an
expert on the whole cloaks T through
phase cleanse situation and his name is
Keith okay so Keith when this whole
thing popped off when the t fou lawsuit
became public I remember cloaks had a
statement on Twitter that he came out
with and if it wasn't neutral it was Pro
faze clan if anything because I do
remember faze banks specifically
retweeting it with comments something
along lines of you know thank you so
much bro generally reacting positively
to it so at the time maybe the biggest
name in the fort night community and T
foo had kind of rustled twitter's
feathers banks was screaming into the
void everybody was asking questions the
likes of ninja Tim the tap man nobody
really knew what was going on it kind of
hit us all by surprise so a lot of
people turn to cloaks in order to sort
of disseminate the information and when
his statement finally came out it came
off kind of neutral he was certainly in
support of banks but at the same time he
was in support of T foo as well because
they've been boys since the beginning of
competitive Fort Lee now to me reading
that statement it really looks like
cloaks is trying to make a point about
who they're really fighting with here
it's not banks or these front-facing
people on Twitter it's really the people
behind the scenes that these contracts
are being negotiated with in the first
place a key part of this whole thing it
correct me if I'm wrong here is just
like one thing I want you guys to
understand is that faze clan is not
necessarily just banks just cloaks just
tea food just rice gum there's the
organization is so much deeper than
that's like an iceberg right so there
are a lot of people who are maybe
puppeteering that's a bit of a intense
word but people who are controlling
things behind the scenes who are wearing
suits who go to board meetings who tow
right that's what you got to understand
about basically it's an organization
like any other right yeah I think that
it's clear and I mean at least from
where I'm sitting it's clear through
Tifa saying and what cloaks is saying
that it's not necesarily banks that
they're trying to have a fight with it
they're not trying to start a Twitter
war it's not YouTube drama this this is
as simple as contracts that are unfair
to the people involved and them trying
to alleviate themselves of the pressure
that that's causing so he comes out with
this initial statement it's kind of
neutral neither here nor there but
curtain if I'm wrong there was a second
statement that skewed really far T foo
right so since the dust is settled on
the lawsuit cloaks has taken some time
off of streaming and off of his like
normal rigorous schedule that said the
day after he made a statement on Twitter
he booted up his twitch account to make
sure that his community knew that cloaks
and T foo are gonna continue to be a duo
they're gonna continue to play together
every night and they're gonna win the
World Cup together
the elephant in the room me and Turner
are still going to be dual partners
there's nothing different between me and
Terry at all so we're gonna fly out in
the World Cup now here's where the
tinfoil hat stuff kind of starts to come
in cloaks changed to support a creator
code from faze cloaks to cloak see now
if you don't think that's a big deal in
fortnight its massive
now my question to you is did any other
parts of his branding change because
that would be very telling right so if
you go and take a look at his twitch
page phase is completely gone that
little F that's usually spinning
underneath him when he's streaming
that's gone the phase merchandise below
the stream that's gone there's no
mention of faze clan anywhere on the
page so you're telling me if I go to
closest which page right now there's not
going to be any basically and branding
anywhere on the platform that they want
eyeballs on yeah exactly
as of May 27th cloaks has not streamed
with the faze clan branding on his page
whatsoever that's kind of shocking yeah
I took it even further and I went and
checked at his Instagram page where many
four night streamers and content
producers have really started to
flourish over the last year and there's
no mention of phase in his bio there
either he calls himself a fortnight team
captain but not phases team captain now
despite the fact that we've just showed
you that on Twitch and on Instagram
cloaks no longer has any of that face
stuff on Twitter and on YouTube all of
the phase branding it still exists so my
last point on this is that if you take a
look at him
game in fortnight on the island where
he's spending most of his time
he's also changed his name from phaz
cloak to cloak see no he's correct me if
I'm wrong but you were telling me before
we went on air that when he's competing
in fortnight he has a team tag and he's
changed that from faze clan to hat man
army something within the tat man yeah
so sometimes when streamers especially
big streamers are streaming on Twitch
they'll tag themselves in a team this is
a way for streamers to like you know
build build up a name for themselves
within a group oftentimes major
streamers will have their mods involved
that kind of thing so instead of cloaks
swimming under phase like he previously
would he started to stream under tap man
army obviously Tim the tap man's group
so when I was doing all my research into
the T foo lawsuit there were
stipulations in there about the certain
branding that T foo had to have when he
was streaming obviously basically and
branding now cloaks correct me if I'm
wrong was signed to basically and before
T foo so it's reasonable to presume that
he is on the same if not a very similar
contract as T foo would this removal of
BAE's branding from some of his channels
and and some of his social media
accounts have any bearing on violating
that contract how do these two things
interact yeah so that's kind of exactly
what made me start to look into this in
the first place a lot of what cloak
seems to be doing with his twitch
channel and his socials is right in line
with what phase didn't want t food to do
with his contract so from my standpoint
if cloaks and teef who have anything
close to similar contracts this would be
in direct violation of what he's
supposed to be doing as a content
creator under the phase name so if you
guys are fans of cloaks in t foo you'll
know that for quite a while now they've
been planning on moving in together
they've talked about a house with zero
ping where they'll both vlog and it'll
be awesome and the win the World Cup
together well this kind of came to
fruition on May 28 cloaks had a stream
where he was talking about how T foo was
moving in the next day all this stuff
and coming in there's a bunch of boxes
with computer parts it was then where he
kind of hinted at exactly what we're
talking about I mean it involves doing
stuff but turning moves in tomorrow
you're gonna be staying here guys room
ready you got all the [ __ ]
sent to the house so me and Turner are
gonna be doing some crazy [ __ ] I'm
talking to face to figure out what I
want to do yeah they say that correctly
I'm reading off a script right here so
just to sort of catch you up we've got a
pro for tonight player signed to faze
clan
removing phase branding from this twitch
account at his Instagram account moving
in with his ex teammate who still is
teammate who may or may not be starting
his own org so if you guys have your
tinfoil hat I'd suggest putting it on
now because this next point is a little
wild I can't wait
so recently while t Foos been streaming
he's had this little Patrick the star
logo over top of his mouse because he's
doing this brand deal with final mess
well the other day cloaks had the exact
same deal going on on his page where his
mouse was being covered because he had
this prototype going and nobody was
allowed to see it they said that no I
didn't i just showed mouse
that's why I happened to they just gets
my do show mess or anything like that I
could just add my stream so much like we
were talking about with the contract and
the socials it's the same thing with
these brand deals that was what everyone
was talking about when the lawsuit drama
was going on you can't have brand deals
with brands that will compete with a
brand that phase is sponsored by let's
say SteelSeries so if t foo and cloaks
are doing a mouse brand deal with final
mouse then what does phase have to say
about that ignoring a phase clay and
brand deal is almost certainly against
the terms of at least t fus contract and
probably closest I mean I think we at
least have to assume that given the
information we've presented you guys so
far all right so there you have it I
want to thank my guest for this episode
Keith's cap stick thank you for doing
all the work in this case maybe I should
have you home more often and I want to
reiterate before we go before you hit
the comment section then again no
official statement regarding cloaks and
phase clans current relationship has
been made we've reached out to cloaks
we've reached out to faze clan we
haven't gotten anything back from them
yet so we don't know but the evidence is
there and the onus is on you to make up
your minds thanks for watching if you
want more content like this hit the sub
button and ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up art Instagram
Twitter and Facebook pages
[Music]